what is eu for health
eu for health will help make european
health care systems more resilient
in the face of future health crises the
program aims to invest
in health threat surveillance emergency
supplies and health workers
so eu countries are not caught off guard
in the future
it will help promote health and disease
prevention and make sure medicines and
medical devices
are available and affordable
doesn't the eu already have healthcare
support programs
of course the eu already has
health-related programs in place
you might remember horizon europe for
health research or
esf plus which provides better access to
health care for vulnerable people
or even digital europe which will help
modernize our clinics
where will the eu for health funds go
the european parliament successfully
negotiated a trickling of health funds
in the eu budget
and 5.1 billion euros will go to
european countries and citizens
some of the funds will be for ngos or
action by health bodies like the world
health organization
all of this will strengthen
international cooperation
to better face health threats
so is eu for health only preparing for
the next pandemic then
no eu for health has a much bigger scope
the eu is looking to reduce inequalities
in access to health care
it will focus not only on future health
threats but also on research into
and treatment of non-communicable
diseases
like cancer and diabetes and promote
healthy lifestyles
shouldn't health experts have their say
too
[Music]
absolutely if the eu wants eu for health
to be successfully implemented
parliament says it needs oversight from
a steering group
made up of health experts
representatives from member states
and even patient organizations